I'm prime time tonight here on c-span
the Senate later today is expected to
approve Richard Cordray as the head of
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
here senate banking committee chair Jim
Johnson commenting about this along with
Senator Jack Reed senator Warren because
it really was for idea and unflagging
support of the CFPB that has brought us
to this very happy day where we're a
step closer to confirming Richard
Cordray which is a giant leap forward
for consumer protection in the United
States I had the privilege of working
with chairman Johnson and others on the
committee including my colleague Senator
Durbin who was the Majority Whip and
making sure that this provision stayed
within the mark and that we were able to
come to a successful conclusion with
dodd-frank but today is a day in which
we really sort of being on the verge of
standing up and fully authorizing the
CFPB it took us a while to get here but
with a permanent director we can
regulate financial products from non
banks including debt collectors payday
lenders and check cashes in fact one of
the points that we made is this is going
to even the playing field no longer will
we have a regulated banking sector and a
unregulated non-bank bank sector that
could in fact pull in the opposite
direction we're going to have we hope
consistent regulation that's going to be
thoughtful and I believe that is going
to be the case we have new mortgage
rules stronger oversight of Wall Street
and also the CFPB was organized really
to play a major role along with our
other regulators and preventing
financial fraud protecting responsible
financial institutions and ensuring fair
competition and most of all and
particularly it was created to protect
consumers protect them by educating them
protect them by regulating financial
transactions and doing that in a way
that would provide transparent
marketplace that would benefit both
consumers and businesses of financial
education has been one of the
key areas of concern they have been
given rulemaking powers to not only
educate the public but also to preempt
and head off unfair deceptive and
abusive financial practices and products
it has already returned more than 425
million dollars to consumers six million
consumers have benefited from the CFPB
already and I'm particularly pleased
because I worked to incorporate within
the CFPB the office of servicemembers
Affairs which is led by Holly Petraeus
and we are paying particular attention
to the plight of the men and women of
our armed services who many times find
themselves because they're away from
home at the mercy of financial operators
one as scrupulous as they should be I
learned that as a lieutenant a captain
in the 82nd m1 division counseling
troops and trying to write letters to
people dunt Dunning them literally for
loans they never should have been given
in the first place so that's one thing
I'm very very pleased to see take place
we are going forward with director
Cordray to not only seek input from the
public but also from financial services
industry one of the most refreshing
things has been the reception by some
business leaders to Richard Cordray
saying he's been fear he's been
transparent that he has listened to us
that he has made appropriate changes and
that's the kind of regulatory
environment that we want to continue not
only has this Bureau shown it can be
effective but basically what it is done
is demonstrated that a transparent
competitive marketplace is good for
consumers and as good for businesses and
so we're very pleased today that we're
on the verge was formal confirmation
with that let me recognize really the
visionary who prodded us inspired us
cajoled us and today we should recognize
her vision senator Elizabeth Warren
thank you Thank You Senator Reid I am
delighted to stand here today
Senator Reid uh it was nearly four years
ago when I first came to see him with
nothing more than an idea and a great
sales pitch how about if you take on
some of the most powerful lobbyists in
order to build an agency that would help
a lot of families across this country
and Senator Reid said yes and he was
there from the beginning he was there
from the beginning and the design and
there from the beginning and fighting to
get it through in the concern the
dodd-frank bill and he also rightly
pointed out it was his idea to put in an
office of servicemember Affairs that's
one of those little lines in a bill
sometimes that you don't pay a lot of
attention to it turned into something
amazing Holly Petraeus now runs it it
has gotten homes back from service
members who were cheated out of them
it's done a recent recovery for service
members who were tricked on car loans
they're getting about six and a half
million dollars back it's been out there
advocating and it's been out there
educating provided a place for veterans
active duty folks to learn about their
rights to learn better about what that
financial marketplace looks like it's
got a strong advocate in Holly Petraeus
and that's all there because of the
leadership of Jack Reed and so I'm just
delighted to have a chance to say
publicly how grateful I am I also want
to say grateful I am to Senator Johnson
the chair of the Banking Committee who
so carefully so patiently saw through a
big and complicated dodd-frank bill and
protected this consumer agency and made
sure that we would get the strong
watchdog that the American people
deserve it's been two years that rich
Cordray has been waiting for this vote
and now he's going to get we've got one
more vote to go but it is clear the
Consumer Agency has survived it has
survived this confirmation means that
the Consumer Financial
tection Bureau is the law it is here to
stay this confirmation means that the
American people get the watchdog that
they deserve they get a watchdog that
will help push tricks and traps out of
the financial system help get rid of the
fine print and help hold large financial
institutions accountable this
confirmation means that big change is
possible here in Washington's sometimes
Goliath loses to David and that's what's
happened this time so I'm very pleased
to be here with you senator Reed glad to
take any questions any question much of
the debate over the last few years have
been has been focused on Republicans
demanding three significant changes to
the CFPB in order to consider a nominee
now that that fight has kind of been put
to the sideline is there any interest in
potentially revisiting the CFPB to make
more minor changes changes that both
parties might be able to agree on now
that that you know kind of intractable
debate has been set aside well i'm going
to ask Senator warrant a comment also
but you know anytime we can improve an
agency we should do that but the design
of the CFPB was very similar to the
financial regulatory agencies
particularly OCC where you have a
director their operations are
essentially funded not through the
appropriations process but through the
assessment process and as a result what
you have is the ability to any
independence to operate in the best
interest in this case of consumers so I
think the overall design is something we
through very very strongly about but if
there's any technical issues that can be
improved and you know with experience
I'm sure there will be I think I would
be happy to consider them look at and I
would only add to what Senator Reid said
he's right of course you always want to
consider any possible improvements to
any agency and the Consumer Agency is no
exception on that but we built a good
strong agency and no one is looking
weaken it and so I think we just stand
firm there anyone else yes ma'am there
was any speeches or any comments last
night that really moved the ball forward
or what it was like in the room and then
and then what's that how is our things
for the CFPB different today for
consumers or for their customers for the
banks with Cordray confirmed what
Elizabeth's coming oh she's the hot you
come in on the room well I see my
comment to vary the spirit of the room
was a candid discussion which if we
discussed publicly would sort of
undermine that spirit and I I think it's
a good spirit that we should continue
not not not preempt so let me then ask
senator Warren tachometer bond that
where the CFPB is today reverse these of
the where it would be yesterday any
cloud of uncertainty hanging over the
Consumer Agency has now disappeared the
Consumer Agency is here to stay here to
stay in a strong form and I would add to
and something I think Elizabeth knows
Richard better than I but this is an
extraordinary individual a great public
servant somebody who's earned the
respect of everyone who has had the
privilege to deal with them and indeed
as I suggested my comments either the
financial industry also but we have
someone I think who can build a strong
organization based upon his skill so I
think we're doubly lucky one we have
director but two we have Richard Cordray
as the director so that's a point she
really is introducing legislation that
would create a dedicated inspector
general for the CFPB is that something
that you would object to do you think it
would gain support I think that's
something you know that we should look
at I mean I don't have a predisposition
either way I think first of all what we
want to do and I think again I feel sort
of
I'm next the person who was the
architect so I'm but i think our notion
was in order to have the kind of sort of
gravitas and also effectiveness like the
other banking regulators they have to be
built along similar lines and so I be
curious as to you know what is he what's
the situation with inspector general is
occ or FDIC etc but that's something
that is in the process of a hearing we
could easily undertake so sufficient
that's you know that's the kind of data
that will look for and again I senator
Portman is a very thoughtful and
experienced individual on someone who's
very serious and and someone who's
proposal have to be considered seriously
I think that's right think I think
Senator Reid said it all anywhere yes
you know what wouldn't when you look
back what what do you think the catalyst
was for this to kind of get decided
right now being that it took two years
what for Senator Warren what do you what
do you think led to this moment great
senator warrant oh yeah I'd put it with
two parts one is I think we've made the
strong case for the Consumer Agency no
I'll say that differently the Consumer
Agency has made the strong case for the
Consumer Agency it's now been there for
two years doing the job you know
recovering money from for families that
have been cheated providing a complaint
hotline for people who've been tricked
protecting our service members our
seniors our students so it's been out
there doing the job and rich Corddry has
been out there doing the job two years
ago when he and I stood next to
President Obama and the Rose Garden he
was known for his terrific background
for having been a strong attorney
general in Ohio oh but no one knew what
kind of director he would be for the
Consumer Agency we've had two years of
rich being a terrific director and so I
think that has been a powerful part of
this conversation
I think it's fair to say that not only
has the industry praised rich the
community banks have praised him the
credit unions have supported in consumer
groups all around the country but here's
part of it both Democrats and
Republicans have said that he is doing
an excellent job so I think that was a
big part of getting us to where we are
today we we now have information we have
facts we've seen it work it has worked
yeah take a final question do you think
that there's more that the agency in
potentially Richard Cordray have more
credibility because the nuclear option
wasn't used to get it confirmed or does
that really not matter I think what
matters and again I'll in many respects
just echo what senator Warren says
they've already established credibility
legitimacy fairness with not only the
consumers and American public but with
the financial industry you know when he
when you get comments from the finance
industry that they were sort of
surprised at how open-minded how
thoughtful how attentive they were to
you know making their rules effective
and efficient that's a good sign and
then you know 425 million million
dollars being returned to people that's
a practical benefit so I think basically
echoing again Elizabeth though the
record that's been established this is
an agency that works and now it's going
to be you know fully and deployed and
unquestioned in terms of its authority
and that's a good day for everyone it is
actually not just handed out it you'll
forgive me for two seconds being extra
dorky here but there really is an
interesting point right in the heart of
this you know when Congress passed
dodd-frank three years ago right now
there was a real concern among some
about would the agency be able to do
what it aspired to do we knew what its
intent was and we we built a structure
we thought would work
but would it really take off and so
Congress took the position the Senate
did of let's below belt and suspenders
in this will build the Consumer Agency
and will give the consumer agency the
authority to write the rules on
mortgages going forward remember this
economy was broken one lousy mortgage at
a time so the question of what to do in
the mortgage market was probably the
most central consumer issue of the
moment so they put a set of rules into
dodd-frank saying if the consumer agency
doesn't come up with rules here's what
controls here's here are the new rules
and these will go into effect
automatically rich Cordray led the
agency through the process of developing
the rules for issuing new mortgages they
have been so widely applauded by
consumer groups by industry groups who
say this helps us get to a cleaner more
honest mortgage market a level playing
field as Senator Reid said that
essentially everybody wanted it they
said don't go back to the dodd-frank
rules we like what this agency is doing
so that's just one more example it
partly does to the answer to your
question to the agency proved itself in
multiple ways and on the hardest task it
was given it proved within two years
that it could do a darn good job on
behalf of the American people thank you
all very much thank you thank you
we just heard from Senator Warren she
helped lead the implementation of the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau as
a special assistant to the president
then President Obama later nominated
Richard Cordray to lead the bureau we're
about mr. Cordray's nomination in a
moment but